it can be difficult to differentiate
between a food allergy and food
intolerance and with holiday meals
coming up again right around the corner
it's best to know what foods you need to
stay away from we connected with a food
intolerance expert on symptoms reaction
times
[Music]
Dr Jill Hart is a biochemist and a food
intolerance expert at York test she says
the clearest way to tell the difference
between a food allergy and an
intolerance symptoms and reaction time
allergies are the immediate reaction to
a food like swelling of the mouth
diarrhea or vomiting food intolerance or
sensitivities can take up to two days to
appear and those symptoms are very
wide-ranging so you might get anything
from IBS Sirius
digestive problems bloating
through to skin symptoms migraines
headaches and even things like low
energy and low mood the most common food
allergies are to milk eggs shellfish and
sesame allergies tend to be developed
through childhood or adulthood and at
that point are lifelong but food
intolerance can develop at any age and
it's not necessarily permanent we can
actually find out from that small blood
sample exactly what people are reacting
to York test is the UK's market leader
in food sensitivity testing it has hubs
in the United States the test identifies
up to 200 different foods in anyone over
the age of two in a recent study the
company found 80 percent of the people
who took a simple blood test felt better
after removing the food identified in
the test
Dr Hart says after you remove the
problem food from your diet give it two
to three months to get your gut health
back in check and then you can try to
reintroduce it back a little bit at a
time to see if you still react to those
Foods